[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
so langsam geht's zum jahresende zu und
vielleicht ist es bei euch auch so dass
ihr jetzt schon einige plätzchen reste
habt ich muss sagen zur weihnachtszeit
hin freue ich mich immer auf lebkuchen
und plätzchen auf alles was man so backt
aber so kurz nach weihnachten und zum
jahreswechsel bin ich schon dort immer
froh wenn die plätzchen dann irgendwann
verschwinden und falls ihr noch einige
plätzchen reste übrig habt dann könnt
ihr heute dieses rezept nach machen denn
ich habe mir gedacht die plätzchen reste
nehmen wir doch jetzt einfach machen
eine leckere füllung raus und backt
einen kuchen und schon hefekuchen den
gibt es ja wirklich in verschiedenen
ländern es gibt deutschen hefekuchen es
gibt in holland in der türkei heißt der
könig der auch ganz gerne babka also
egal wie er geformt wird er sich immer
ganz anders aus und ich dachte mir
einfach kommen da mache ich jetzt auch
leckere füllung draus ich mache das
ganze als kastenform aber ihr könnte
theoretisch auch einen großen muss
zupacken und stadt eine nuss füllung
einfach eine platzieren resteverwertung
füllung machen jetzt mache ich erstmal
den hefeteig dafür verwende ich einen
heim würfel hefe 40 gramm zucker 2
esslöffel warmes wasser 250 gramm mehl
da könnt ihr weizen oder dinkel
verwenden ein eigelb 125 gramm milch
darf gern lauwarm sein einen halben
teelöffel salz und 40 gramm butter genau
das sind alle zutaten
und jetzt könnt ihr den hefeteig
entweder mit den händen verkneten oder
einfach mit der küchenmaschine ich mache
das jetzt hier einen halben würfel ihr
könnt aber auch ein flexten trockenhefe
nehmen das geht auch gut aber ihr könnt
auch wenn ihr frische hefe wenn ich
immer auf vorrat habt könnt ihr auch die
hefe einfrieren es verringert ist so ein
bisschen die trieb eigenschaft aber
wirklich unwesentlich also ich finde man
merkt nicht so wirklich dollar ihr könnt
die wirklich zu beeinflussen und dann
einfach auftauen lassen und
weiterverwenden oder innen trocken hilfe
deswegen hat man eigentlich also ich
habe deswegen immer hilfe zu hause ja
auch wenn ich immer frisch dann meistens
eingefahren hierfür wasser und zucker in
die rührschüssel dann kurz berühren
[Musik]
jetzt kommen alle anderen zutaten dazu
da hefeteig solltet ihr einfach nur
darauf achten dass salz und fett zum
schluss dazu kommen das mag die chance
zu geben
vielleicht der einzige mensch auch als
kraft ich weiß es immer schade wenn
etwas übrig bleibt deswegen sagt der
letzte rest drin
und wie gesagt entweder mit den händen
kneten oder mit der küchenmaschine für
etwa zehn minuten damit auch schön
geschmeidig
oder er holt euch dennis die maschine
und entwickelt dann ist den hefeteig
[Musik]
für
und jetzt ist der teig fertig für mich
ein bisschen ungewohnt weil ich
normalerweise immer hier verteilt in
großen portionen macht 500 gramm mehl
aufwärts und das ist die hälfte weil ich
gleich ganze in der kastenform machen
will und wer meinen job kennt der weiß
dass mein muss oft immer so riesig wird
wie so ein ganzes blech voll da fühlte
ich den ganzen oben aber hat man eine
kleinere möglich
wenn ihr eine küchenmaschine habt mit
hits der funktion wird es zum beispiel
die cam ward connect dann könnt ihr
während des knotens auch schon die hitze
dazu einschalten so auf 30 grad dann
wird der teig schon schön warm und er
gibt dann später einfach ein bisschen
schnell auf und dann freue mich den
normalwerten kugel
legt ihn in die schüssel zurück und dann
könnt ihr ihn auch in der maschine noch
mal aufgehen lassen für eine halbe
stunde bis stunde bis er sich verdoppelt
hat oder wenn ihr in den dampf backofen
habt dann auch gerne im dampf backofen
bei der stufe 34 grad mit dampf trocknet
das nehme ich auch nicht aus und es geht
doppelt so schnell also da muss man echt
nicht so lange warten aber auch hier mit
der hitze wirklich optimal abdecken und
nicht vergessen
der hefeteig ist jetzt aufgegangen also
kann sie es mit der füllung weitergehen
wie gesagt nehmt einfach was ihr noch zu
hause habt plätzchen kekse
cranberries trockenfrüchte marzipan das
könnt ihr alles benutzen ich habe jetzt
hier meine 200 gramm plätzchen mischung
100 gramm nüsse die habe ich jetzt
einfach ganz bunt gemischt zwar
esslöffel cacau ein eiweiß etwas milch
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr auch noch
sorte kernel fudge nehmen das sind so
kleine karamellbonbons und die gibt es
in fort campbell und in quito sehr
lecker und ich habe jetzt hier soll ich
kann weil ich auch schon relativ süß bin
mit den plätzchen die sind ja alle muss
man sagen voller zucker und deswegen
kommt jetzt hier auch kein zusätzlicher
sogar mit dazu und dann kann man das so
schön ausgleichen genau jetzt
zerkleinerte einfach alles weil es ihr
keinen mixa habt könnt ihr zum beispiel
auch die kekse in einen beutel geben und
mit dem nudelholz mit dem ausfall starb
drüber rollen oder auch so ein kleiner
und kleiner ich mache das jetzt hier
oben erwartet ich mache erst die müsse
und dann die plätze noch dazu
[Musik]
da geht auch so ein bisschen mein
vorsatz jedes plätzchen muss angebissen
werden kaputt oder kleiner ich sie
einfach alle ihr mixa aber ich muss
sagen irgendwann kann man plätzchen und
keksen nicht mehr sehen dann ist
man kann doch sortenrein machen also
wenn jetzt nur vanillekipferl und ich
hab dann macht er halt wenn nötig aber
ich bin zur bunt gemischt einhalten
schönen weihnachtsgeschenk
[Musik]
da gebe ich jetzt noch cacau und so
haben wir jetzt eine schöne dunkle
füllung
eiweiß zum binden
rettungs milch da müsste jetzt mal
gucken ob ihr die kompletten 50 gramm
braucht oder ein bisschen weniger weil
es ja auch jetzt du echt drauf ankommt
was für kekse und was für reste ihr habt
deswegen es sollte einfach eine schöne
verstreicht bahre masse entstehen
[Musik]
nämlich etwas mehl
und meinen hefeteig
und dann wollt ihr den einfach schön
eckig aus
jetzt hier auch die kleine silikon matze
die habt 40 mal 40 zentimeter größe und
das passt jetzt auch ganz gut weil ich
ja echt nur so eine halbe menge an
hefeteig habe
jetzt einfach immer wieder den teig
bisschen drehen und wenden das ist schön
rechteck wird
ich habe den heute ein bisschen weicher
zubereitet deswegen brauche ich heute
ein bisschen mehr mühe beim ausräumen
weil ich merke dass er ansonsten so die
form so verteilt aber meistens wenn ich
ihn ein bisschen fester zu bereit also
direkt per mail ein knetet dann brauche
ich ganz wenig oder sogar gar kein mehl
zum ausbau
dann schön die füllung darauf verteilen
und glatt streichen
kriegt echt gut
wo was richtig gut waren so harzer käse
verkehrt sich hier mit rein ich finde
aber klickt ihr einfach ein tolles aroma
durch die haferflocken
die mag ich gern ja
glatt streichen
[Musik]
und das ganze schön auf rollen und da
nehme ich mir immer die bak hatte so ein
bisschen zu hilfe dann kann man schön
gleichmäßig aufholen
und jetzt könnt ihr das entweder frei
auf einem blech backen oder ihr nehmt
eine backform ich habe jetzt hier so
eine glas backformen von der borgia die
ist für den ofen geeignet
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch auch noch
wir waren ja
letztes jahr in der türkei bei
fenerbahce istanbul haben gesehen wie
glas frauen hergestellt werden und
gerade diese botschaft kam das sind ja
formen aus borosilikatglas und
borosilikatglas ist ein ganz besonderes
glas es hätte nämlich
temperaturschwankungen von minus 40 grad
bis über 200 grad aus das heißt ihr
könnt jetzt zum beispiel was vorbereiten
und einfrieren und dann wirklich was
gefroren ist einfach in den heißen
backofen geben und könnte so auch
gerichte wunderbar vorbereiten also das
ist muss ich sagen echt seien sehr
praktisch und das will ich jetzt hier
rein
jetzt aber vorher noch zur hälfte zu
schneiden
und flechten diesen luft vertrieben
[Musik]
egal welche backform ihr nehmt auf jeden
fall vorher einfetten mit back trance
prayer oder mit butter aus pendeln dann
kommt es hier schön rein und dadurch
dass ihr das jetzt in einer form habt
das ganze eben in die höhe während er
das jetzt ohne form markt also wieso
muss doch dann packt einfach so ein
bisschen in die breite da könnt ihr
entscheiden wie er das eben haben möchte
und ich stelle das jetzt in den kalten
backofen schalten dann auf 170 grad so
kann nämlich der teig während des
auswahlprozesses einfach auch schon auf
gehen und ich gebe noch dampf stufe 1
mit dazu beim backofen dann bleibt der
hefeteig oder der hilfe kommen eben auch
richtig saftig
[Musik]
der hierfür zum sitz fertig und ich habe
ihn noch mit bisschen aprikosenmarmelade
bestrichen dann bekommt dann schönes
land und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr noch
süßen schnee drauf strömen und ich würde
sagen troger darf heute probieren
trauer was macht ihr normalerweise mit
plätzchen resten gibt zwar gibt es drei
plätze den rest also bei uns gibt's
schon plätzchen und das bei uns nie also
die sind eigentlich direkt zum zwei
tagen spätestens zwei recht dann ist das
rezept nichts für dich warum ich hab
plätzchen praktisch zerkleinert als
füllung als rest dieser wertung
bitte habt ihr plätzchen restaurant la
lotta ist bei mir schon so irgendwann
kann ich sie immer sehen mich also
nachdem zehnter war neben kippt weil ich
liebe die mit marmelade das war sehr
stark ich weiß dass
ich euch lieb außer terrace mit der
ballade sind sofort weg ja schon aber es
kommt darauf an wie viel man auch macht
und dann eigentlich macht man das noch
nur einmal und danach nie wieder
eigentlich schon aber es gibt also es
gibt schon welche die in der leckereien
aus der diese welt gruppe bei facebook
also ich finde die betteln sie da
richtig mit plätzchen die eine macht so
20 verschiedene die andere 30
verschieden und wenn ich so überlegen
machte nicht nur ein blech gruppe also
pro sorte sind schon auf 234 bleche mal
verteilt es ja auch und dann eskaliert
es immer ich habe es letztes jahr zum
aller ersten mal gemacht plätzchen
normalerweise habe ich immer mit oma
gemacht oder soja aber einmal bis knapp
danach habe ich sechs ist nie wieder
weil es so ein aufwand ist ich dachte so
einmal ausräumen tust du alles
ausstechen aber dann muss ja noch mal
ausfallen und dann noch mal und dann
noch mal zum spaß mit kindern und vor
ich mache gern einmal geht kann dann ist
es meinen plätzchen resteverwertung ist
hefekuchen
der ist noch lang
das heute gute mischung aus allem
ich kann nichts sagen was da drin ist
jetzt alles
bei nacht nicht
alles
einmal von anfang november bis ende
dezember
[Gelächter]
alle plätzchen die gemacht wurden nach
schicker vanillekipferl muss schmecken
muss acton keine ahnung alles war gut
alles gut ja man sich aus dem spiel
ein 2 3 die zitronen bruder zur wirklich
genau am besten noch mit
710 schnecken ok seitdem rätseln bin ich
sowieso
wenn aber was ich auch mag ich diese
aprikosenmarmelade weil die macht es
auch so fruchtig
verkehren da etwas frustriert aber ich
glaube das ist richtig gut also probiert
gerne aus wie gesagt alle kate fress
bitte ihr so habt wenn ihr keine
plätzchen risse habt könnt ihr auch
einfach plätzchen kekse mission ihr
könnt ja lotus kekse vollkornkekse haar
verträgt alles zusammen mischen und dann
habt ihr einen schönen geschmack
wir machen ein mal sondern richtige nur
solo nur mit lotus war also wenn ihr
euch das wünscht dass wir in einfachen
lotus live gepäck machen dann schreibt
gerne noch mehr
als es eskaliert wieder bis zur nächsten
woche bis
rezept gibt natürlich auch siemens
blog.de und zum nachbarn
[Musik]
richtig gut